this week we are training like Zac Efron
[Laughter]
so I don't know if you know but Zac
Efron has a YouTube channel now and I
saw this video of saffron and Nina
Dobrev working out in this very location
and I thought it would be a really cool
opportunity because he's really known
for his body he like heels like that
fitness dude right now I would assume
Zac's workout routine is like 90% ABS
it's just like all ABS in different
directions
it is only a week but we're going to
definitely like learn a lot and probably
feel a lot different by the end of it if
we don't look a little different I've
never had like a personal trainer will
they show me some stuff I don't know
probably that's the gap if you're just
one tell you that we're both in this
together all right we got to get our
head into the game let's get over it I
can't believe they let us in here
I'm Johnny Fontana I'm a trainer and
this is my gym it's called vitro for
most of our clients workouts are like an
hour long they start off with some
movement based score warm-up type stuff
right before the main work set it's
either something like kind of more
explosive or more isolating and then we
do a main work set typically which is
like three or four exercises that we're
just gonna keep going through for three
or four rounds and then we usually do
some sort of like cardio abs at the end
we'll end with some of the recovery
protocols if you have just so that you
can sleep better tonight feel well
rested coming into the workout tomorrow
so what do you guys as goals what do you
want to get out of this I have a kind of
bulkier build and I'd like to kind of
get it more you know svelte tone learn
more workouts to build towards that and
more aesthetics I think for me I'm
interested in like finding a way to slim
down and tone without feeling like I
have to be on a treadmill for an hour
but I'm finding a lot of times it feels
like it's just like running into the
ground with the same stuff and not
seeing that much result we'll start
probably doing really similar moves but
then we'll start to break it off a
little more you're gonna be doing a
little bit more explosive type moves
Kelsea we're gonna do whole movement
total body type moves that are gonna be
with like free weights so that way if
you go to a gym you can kind of just
pick up a dumbbell or kettlebell and not
have to worry about fighting people for
machines all right well I'm excited I
think we should get to it right get to
it right - all right this is how we warm
up right yeah that's a warm-up all right
so we're gonna start with some movement
prep stuff which basically means like
moving to get ready to move in more
intense situations this is all a
bodyweight we're hitting a little bit
everything with this so you getting the
little legs we're getting a little trunk
twist which is good for your spine and
back so stay nice and tall at these I
want you guys to try to flex your quads
and lock your legs out this is like the
best way to find out if you have a good
core or if it's a weak it need some work
lay down on the band and you want to
find the spot where your back is the
most arch your low back and then all I
want you to do to start is focus on
keeping this thing on the floor so if
your back comes up it'll snap
so this is engage you're like the actual
core muscles and not just like your
six-pack abs with the actual core which
is called your transverse abdominus
you're gonna keep everything where it is
we're gonna pull your feet up off the
floor and kind of make me a little
tabletop with your legs yep and then now
cuz you guys are both still able to hold
the band down you're gonna go slowly
kicking one leg out like a bicycle I
feel like so we're doing like
essentially a circle but we're trying to
find the max range of motion in the
shoulder
[Music]
so there's a move that no matter how
strong or not strong you are everyone
should be doing you know keep our arms
long and just move just the shoulder
blades so Chuck the hits and then yep
it's much range of motion as you can get
up and down we find a lot of people have
improperly working shoulder blades a lot
um I like the front shoulder pain or
just shoulder pain in general and it's
typically said their shoulder blades
don't work well all right so we're gonna
split up the sleds ones gonna do the
sled get a little cardio work the other
ones gonna get some ab work so right
here you're just holding while they're
pushing goes down and back
[Music]
and when - one more round switch it
comes back on the sled
this thing is great for inflammation
which is soreness so this thing is
negative to 35 Fahrenheit my heart is
beating really fast and I can't tell if
it's from the workout that I just did or
from like this fight-or-flight panic
mode that I'm currently entering as my
body feels a turtle oh god yeah
oh maybe like a minute I smell
[Music]
all right so day one's done anyone's
done how you guys doing oh I'm feeling
good I'm super excited about this week
yeah I'm really excited to learn a lot
more you guys looked actually like
really good yeah I want to go put my
clothes on cos I'm good to go due to was
less assessment and way more full body
workout really kind of actually going in
there and pushing our bodies got me
super hyped yeah day two
I don't know what else to expect but I
had a blast alright let's see let's see
where's Lissy was F I'm talking about
right
so day three was cool it was a little
different cuz it's when me and Kelsey
split up Kelsey was getting her box on
me it was a pretty intense circuit
I need up get up and hop in the shower
but it's a deceit take my pants off I'm
too tired to do anything else I had so
much fun today it was really fun to kind
of like find different ways for me to do
my cardio but also to still do my weight
training I think honestly one of the
biggest differences between having a
celebrity body and having you know my
own it's just time and the right
resources
I stayed up way too late last night and
now I'm really tired and I didn't get a
coffee cuz I'm late then I'm just oh my
god I know I'm gonna have a good time
but I don't want to go so we're working
on mobility today we're gonna focus on
working on the hips in different
stretching mechanism and Johnny's time
cheffy in 2000 he's the stretchy guys
so your finish of our workout I'm baking
under some infrared lights for a metro
minute I don't know
[Music]
you know Johnny's never steered me wrong
so it kind of feels nice today was not
bad you know he I was doing a lot of
like hip kind of like stretchy stuff
nothing that was to heavy lifting but it
did strengthen some things that I'd you
know need to be strengthened
apparently tomorrow is called Friday
that's literally what he calls it and I
the fear of God is in me so I'm nervous
you Friday was just like crazy really
intense but at the same time I never
felt pushed to the point where I wanted
to give up
Kelsey crushed it you did see you man so
I just finished you Friday and I feel so
proud it actually was so hard but I
wasn't miserable I wasn't dying I mean I
was dying but like in a good way you
know what you got to do a lot to get a
lot you know and just go lay here for a
second I think about what we did hoo-boy
so we've been going through this for
about a week now or put all together see
how you guys do it
[Music]
I'm doing the thing I could do last time
yep
solid swole it much better well I mean
you've been going like a half an hour so
this is called a Pinelli device and
basically it measures your cardio
metabolic this is going to tell you
ideal heart rate for the most amount of
fat burn calories while you're working
out so the important thing with this is
you can't talk you just have to run
we got your like ideal fat-burning zone
which is in like the 140 to 160 heart
rate so if you trade in that hurry
you're gonna burn the most minute fat
and calories so just really trying to
push and get more comfortable in that
heart rate essentially and your vo2 will
increase your maximum fat burn was at
that peak right there
and I was at a 167 heart rate so
anything in this like gap is a good spot
to be burning yeah so based on the
conversations that we were having
throughout the week it really seemed
that they learned a lot about how their
body moved so I think just really
learning a bit about themselves they
really kind of were surprised about the
different things that they were figuring
out okay so wow we worked out like Zac
Efron for a week and I was sore yep
I'm so sore now I'm still sore yeah feel
like even though it's only been a week
we learn things that we can apply to our
workouts just for the rest of our
FitLife their workouts that worked out
parts of our muscles that you think
you're working out but there's like no
there's another muscle there and it's
time to engage that I was learning
something new every day and it was very
movement based I was pushing things
across the floor and I learned where my
own weaknesses were and like also felt
like I improved on some of those even
though it was this short period of a
week overall are we looking like Zac
Efron now no but yet well one step
closer to the run status and honestly
that's a glow up in and of itself
[Music]